bonjour pierre emmanuel thomas
merci d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur arte france et vanilla macron
va peut-être donc annoncé et confirmé en
tout cas ce retrait de la force barkan
du mali est ce que c'est une un revers
français ou un revers européen selon
vous
alors
c'est un retrait
un recul géopolitique évidemment non
seulement français mais européen
mais il faut se rendre compte de l'homme
de l'art eric et géopolitiques mondiales
et régionales pour comprendre quels sont
les enjeux par rapport à l'afrique et la
zone sahélienne
nous sommes dans une contexte de
rivalités géopolitiques mondiales entre
les grandes puissances
etats unis russie chine
le le djihadisme comme l'état islamique
mais aussi al qaïda qui s'implantent
dans le sahel
et l'afrique présente de plus en plus
des défis énormes pour l'europe c'est à
dire une progression du jihadisme et en
même temps une démographie très
importante avec une asymétrie de plus en
plus importante entre l'europe et
l'afrique et donc les français
mais aussi les européens ont un intérêt
géopolitique à tenter d'endiguer cette
menace grandissante notamment vis-à-vis
du jihadisme mais aussi de tenter de
d'aidé au développement de l'afrique
pour éviter une immigration massive trop
importante le problème c'est que
évidemment les pays africains eux mêmes
sont en rivalité aussi se sont il ya
beaucoup d'états failli le des
frontières poreuses ils ne s'entendent
pas entre eux pour une stratégie
cohérente et les pays européens aussi
son temps ont des perceptions sécurité
différentes où il ya surtout la france
qui essaye d'agir au sahel pour sa
sécurité mais aussi au nom de la
sécurité européenne mais d'autres états
européens se méfient plus tôt de la
russie et donc il ya un manque de
stratégie globale parce que l'union
européenne est prise entre deux fronts
le front de l'arc de crise au sud du
maroc jusqu'à l'afghanistan ou le sahel
et le choeur avec comme je lai comme je
l ai dit tout à l'heure le le défi
jihadistes et qui progresse aussi vers
le golfe de guinée et l'arc de crise
avec la russie à l'est et alors les
européens et les français aussi risque
de de s'épuiser sur deux fronts en
réalité et le front le plus important le
vrai d'adversaires c'est le djihadisme
ce n'est pas la russie est donc on voit
bien que l'union européenne
qui se dit complémentaire de l'otan se
positionne aussi pour contrer la russie
alors même que la russie n'est pas un
ennemi et s'épuise en afrique en mettant
pas assez de moyens au sud alors que
c'est là que le vrai défi pour l'europe
se trouve en plus il y à la france
évidemment qui de sa position
géographique puissances européennes mais
aussi méditerranéenne a toujours
considéré que devait pas pratiquer la
politique d' équilibre entre l'espace
euro africain
euro-atlantique et euro asiatique
mais et de se poser en leader par
rapport aux autres acteurs européens
mais aussi pour évidemment soutenir son
pré carré sa propre zone d'influencé en
rivalité avec les deux les autres
grandes puissances qui ont aussi leur
propre zone d' influence mais
les européens de l'union européenne ne
sont pas forcément prêts à suivre la
france pour pour cette stratégie globale
qui manque au niveau de l'union
européenne justement est-ce que la
france n'a pas commis l'erreur
finalement de de soutenir les états
faillis dont vous parliez au sahel
on a vu qu'il ya eu des coups d'état
notamment au mali est-ce que ça a été
une erreur de trop miser peut-être sur
la réponse militaire plutôt vous l'avez
dit que la réponse du développement
je crois que
il y a le problème est que il faut
combiner les différentes approches la
réponse militaire était nécessaire mais
pas suffisante évidemment le la france
intervient militairement mais elle n'a
pas les outils pour aider au
développement à construire un état fort
en afrique alors il ya aussi cette idée
de d'exporter je dirais le modèle
européen la démocratie libérale le la
société ouverte mais ça ne fonctionne
pas en afrique ils les pays africains
aux besoins selon moi de d'état fort
avec une police et une justice une
cohésion nationale et ça c'est
extrêmement difficile de l'exporter et
donc la france et les autres pays
européens s'ils agissent militairement
ils n'ont pas ils détiennent pas le
pouvoir sur les autres leviers donc ça
ne peut pas fonctionner mais aussi des
erreurs qui ont été faites en comme les
interventions il ya deux poids deux
mesures la france est intervenue en
libye a provoqué un changement de régime
qui a qui a mis en a qui a permis la
montée en puissance des djihadistes et
donc après on nous sommes intervenus au
mali pour contrer les djihadistes donc
il faut arrêter aussi d'avoir une des
stratégies non cohérente à l'échelle de
toute cette zone il ya lille i à ce
sommet entre l'union européenne et
l'union africaine à bruxelles
aujourd'hui pour discuter d'un nouveau
partenariat stratégique les chefs d'état
africains se disent assez sceptiques que
peut-il en ressortir
en tant qu il ya pas de stratégie
globale de l'union européenne ue point
de vue géopolitique avec
un noyau d'états membres qui sont prêts
à y réfléchir et le mettre en oeuvre ce
sera extrêmement difficile parce que les
attentes sont différentes
et dans la géopolitique mondiale il y a
deux théâtres de plus en plus important
le tertre à gien c'est le théâtre
principal pour la les rivalités de
puissance et le terrain africain monte
en puissance aussi et donc les européens
aimeraient bien avoir une relation
privilégiée avec l'afrique face à ces
défis mais aussi pour des raisons
économiques
de partenariat david continent
eurasien vis-à-vis de l'amérique mais
comme je les dis les états membres sont
divisés et les pays africains aussi
profitent de plus en plus de la
multipolarité pour avoir des
partenariats aussi avec des d'autres
pays comme la chine la russie dans
aucune compétition
géopolitique de plus en plus importante
qui s'installe en afrique et donc il ya
tout un
le partenariat devrait être repensée et
aussi l'union européenne ne peut plus
fonctionner sur ce ce principe de la
société ouverte avec une immigration de
masse en provenance d'afrique car
évidemment ces combinaisons entre la
montée du jihadisme l'islam radical et
l'immigration de masse en europe
était plus en plus un problème de
sécurité pour les européens et comme les
interventions
dont la france est le fer de lance dans
la zone sahélienne qui est la première
ligne de sécurité pour la france l
europe on ne peut pas en même temps
intervenir sans régler ses autres
questions non seulement de démographie
d'immigration de masse de développement
et donc il à nouveau je retombe sur
cette cette problématique de la
stratégie géopolitique globale donc que
l'union européenne ne possède pas encore
merci beaucoup pierre emmanuel thommen
de votre analyse ce matin en direct dans
la matinale arte france